pretty cool in the age of Trump
right-wingers are accused of being too
extreme and they said can you help us
make the case that that's that's not
true I would actually argue the opposite
and I want to lay out the case for you
today that everything from moderate left
to the current Democratic Party the DNC
they actually have a corner exclusively
on the political extreme in the United
States as men right I don't think that
the right wing is such a big tent now I
don't think it's capable of being as
extremist as the left certainly you can
take maybe a 0.1 percent in attribute
when I'm talking about as an actual
platform so what what do you mean okay
let me lay out a case for you and you
can correct me if I'm wrong let's take
the big issues abortion okay most
conservative pro-life will give you that
we believe life begins at conception but
we're past that now roe v wade was
passed so let's look to the super
EXTREME example of the supreme court
well not nominee anymore but just a
four-second had you ever met President
Trump personally not until my interview
in that interview did he ever ask you to
overrule roe v wade no senator what
would he have done if he'd asked senator
I would have walked out the door he's
about to bomb a clinic here's the thing
the middle of a fight from the right is
we just at this point we don't want to
pay for somebody else's abortion and we
want to herb them at this point
certainly the most horrific of them
let's contrast that with the left whose
policy is taxpayer-funded abortion on
demand no questions asked period their
recent presidential candidate and
Hillary Hillary Clinton by the way
didn't specify some only in the first
trimester a couple weeks she believes
that the unborn in the United States
basically up until the head leaves the
birth canal have no constitutional
rights period asking about some comments
that she made over the weekend on Meet
the Press regarding abortion you said
quote the unborn person doesn't have
constitutional rights and my question is
at what point does someone have
constitutional rights and are you saying
that a child on its due date just hours
before delivery still has no
constitutional right under our law that
is the case that's really good I think
that's throwing chillingly scary let's
move on to economics
okay on the right many of us myself
included want a flat tax some people
don't see it an extreme I certainly
don't you make $100,000 per 10,000 make
a million dollars pay under $2,000 that
seems fair to me but let's take that off
the table okay let's take the flat tax
the income tax off the table let's see
we can find a middle ground on the right
the extremist that we are we have we see
that we have a highest corporate tax
rate in the entire industrialized world
and we don't want to lower it to the
lowest rate we just want to lower it to
a rate that's competitive with your oh
so beloved socialist European
counterparts it's extreme to want to
lower the highest corporate tax rate to
a middle level more extreme than Bernie
Sanders being okay with a 90 percent
income tax radical socialist like the
Eisenhower was president
I think the highest marginal tax rate
was something like thank you it was not
when you think about 90 percent you
don't think that's obviously too high
again no good solid we're this is just a
room full of extremists we're being
flagged on the terror watch list right
they're saying Bernie Sanders is extreme
right because he's never been mainstream
okay
is it more extreme to want to lower the
corporate tax rate or allow people to
keep more of what they've earned then
Hillary Clinton wanting to raise the
estate tax the decks death tax to 65%
which by the way is a tax on tax it's
more extreme to believe that you should
be able to keep more of what you earn
it's more extreme for people like us the
extreme right wingers to believe that we
should be competitive with the rest of
the industrialized world
with our corporate tax rates than it is
to want to tax somebody more than a half
on an already tax
let's another race relations considerate
is a racist right this is the argument
when it comes to race sorry it's just
you're so I'd have cut you okay and
check your priveledge okay well let's
get into that on the right the extreme
view that we have is we want to do away
with affirmative action that's the most
extremist view we have that's what
though that's what the flag is for yep
we want to judge people based on the
content of the character as it were I
believe somebody uttered that too with
probably the neighbor of Atlanta fashion
extreme probably white guy let's let's
take that and contrast that with quotas
segregated graduation and safe spaces
that you see in libraries and hard
at their graduation now and even the DNC
going as far as supporting a borderline
terrorist group in black lives matter
it's not extreme to support a group
black lives matter who have been the
root cause of many a top car burning but
it is extreme for us to say hey maybe
you shouldn't support those people who
are burning the cop cars we want to open
a dialogue well do you want to open the
carburetor it's on fire
[Laughter]
climate change this is the one where
were accused of being extreme all the
time again this is for kids who are in
college when they talk about right-wing
extremists let's let's check all the
boxes and you can send me your tweets at
s Crowder most of us on the right I
think most people in this room accept
the concept of climate change I think
most of us if you look at the polls
accept that humans might be a
contributing significant contributing
factor now we're called extremists or
science deniers simply if we don't
believe that it's an imminent
catastrophe that only the federal
government can fix the same people who
run your post office word stream science
and items you know what climate change
might be happening humans might be
contributing but I don't think the EPA
can fix it what let's contrast that with
the left who they believe in carbon
taxes putting entire industries out of
work proposing the punishment of climate
sceptics as Bernie Sanders and
non-scientists guy in chief bill nye we
can bring it up then we have its quote
from Bernie Sanders yeah yeah along with
supporting binding resolutions including
things like population control taken
from the one-child policy of China it's
extreme for us I don't think the federal
government can solve the problem of SUVs
and cow farts but it's not extreme to be
right in line with the policy that led
to babies being drowned in Chinese
bathtubs I just again I know I'm
probably out of fish I don't see the
extremism of guns this is the one of
course right gun-toting rednecks
clinging to your guns and religion let's
talk about this guns okay you're an
extremist if you believe that the Second
Amendment applies to all live by of
law-abiding citizens if you believe that
the Second Amendment is self-explanatory
it applies to all law-abiding citizens
the left considers you an extremist
let's contrast that with the official
dissenting views
and the landmark ala versus DC case
where liberals like justice Stevens
argued that actually private citizens
have no right to own a firearm
whatsoever even if the purposes are
lawful good lord it's extreme for us to
say the Second Amendment allows private
citizens to have firearms but it's not
extreme for Justice Stevens who have
actually said that there is no common
law right to self-defense it's extreme
for me to want to carry if I'm not a
criminal we all support background
checks if you're a felon if you're a
violent criminal you don't get a gun
that's an extreme point of view not to
say you don't have the right to protect
your family this is even getting the
issue of the open borders from the left
the idea that no people are illegal
which of course is apparently far more
moderate than the extreme view of
believing that people should come here
legally and respect the processes in
place like my mother who's illegal
immigrant pays taxes the self-respecting
American system collector who sucker
let's go and the one that's most
important to me we took this is the one
that ever it's easy to talk about social
justice warriors but they don't really
understand the root cause but again it's
all it's all a part of the prism of
leftism freedom of speech here's why you
hate fat land well blue haired feminists
okay why am I in extremists why is
everyone here considered an extremist
what is required to be considered a free
speech extremists to the left okay it's
simple do you believe that the freedom
of speech is absolutely period that do
you believe it nonviolent even offensive
offensive speech is absolute anyone in
this room and you leave that's protected
by the First Amendment yes
recordings are days left you're an
extremist fantastic yeah it's more
extreme to believe that freedom of
speech even offensive speech is absolute
then it is for 51 percent of current
Democrats to want to ban speech and many
of them you wanted to go as far as
simply banning any anti-muslim bigotry
speech and here's the crazy thing right
I'm an extremist because I want a second
let's look let's ask the question who
determines what hate speech is exactly
who decides what extreme speech is
acceptable and here's something but it
isn't it funny that were deemed
extremists by the people who
conveniently isn't it convenient for
them that the big government left that
those answers consistently and
exclusively lie with those in positions
of political power because they can't be
extremists
only people like you and I not possible
that's our the official platform of the
left all of this leads to when we're
talking about free speech which is which
I it's the First Amendment how important
is it
it's remember number one number one
that's remembered I knew is one time
what law do you think that why do you
believe that the Second Amendment is is
important as you're right like freedom
of speech or something because it's
literally right up there with the
freedom of creeps and maybe this is why
are all the things that we've outlined
are so considered extreme this is why
the official platform of the left makes
it incapable for their members to answer
very simple questions on the first
amendment let's see
will you tell us here today simply but
is a long lip I warn you but it's
important will never entertain or
advance a proposal that criminalizes
speech against any religion I think I
would I want to as I said before you
referenced as context for your question
well there's our context on question ask
just asking you you've already let me
ask a new question as you tell us here
today that this administration's
Department of Justice will never
entertain or advance a proposal that
criminalizes speech against any religion
now since you're together that's not a
hard question well actually it is hard
when you make it's really not bad bill
no I'm not an area and user today pretty
you need a number two pencil in Afghan
trawler of Justice will never entertain
or advance a proposal to criminalize
speech against any religion again sir if
you if you have a kid you can't do it
Perez right yeah you that proposed okay
here's my per for here's my case I ask a
question that's my proposal I'm premier
language for this question will you tell
us here today
that this administration's Department of
Justice will never entertain or advance
a proposal that criminalizes speech
against any religion again sir if you'd
be right insert analyze we don't attend
2005 second is conduct I will other
white real but I will think I can we can
straighten this I will not heal I'm just
looking for a way to put that clip in
for a long
time so okay let me read it for those
who weren't clear on the question let me
crystallize it for you for the left to
believe that you are an extremist all
that is required is someone like that to
ask you the question hold on a second do
you promise that you will not sign any
bill or support any bill that
criminalizes any speech of any kind if
you were elected a representative and
you were able to answer that question
yes I promise I will not ban speech of
any kind you're an extremist hey video
is take another clip from the full show
Daily Show at Lada with credit calm /
mug Club words available exclusively $69
a year that's less than six dollars a
month less than two expensive cups of
coffee or you can feed an African child
but just buy coffee or join the mug club
Daily Show a lot of credit calm / mug
club see you there don't feed children